[Music]
this is star talk neil degrasse tyson
here your personal astrophysicist and
today we're going to do a cosmic queries
a cosmic queries with mary roach if you
don't know about her you will by the end
of this broadcast i'll tell you that
right now but first let me introduce my
guest co-host for this episode paul
mercurio paul always good to have you
back there uh it's always great to be
back great to see you and excited
emmy and peabody award winner
for your work on the daily show with
john stewart yes yes yes you got you got
comedy chops that are like authentic and
bona fide and with street cred well
they're not they're his awards i took
him from his office when i left but
they're mine
they're mine now and he's got plenty of
others
yeah he's a tiny man i wrestled him to
the ground and took them from uh yeah no
we uh we um yeah we got we got some
awards for a bunch of
kooky young guys just kind of messing
around and they
yeah it was crazy so yeah
congratulations and thanks for sharing
some of that sort of comedic wisdom and
insight with us thank you star talk
thank you so as you know cosmic queries
you're going to be bringing in questions
to ask of our guest mary roach mary how
the hell are you it's been too long
i know it's been way too long i'm fine
i'm good i'm still alive
you know you've been on the show a
couple of times uh one time we talked
about
uh uh packing for mars getting ready for
a mars trip but you're still here so you
didn't you didn't go on that one
i'm on a waiting list yeah well anyways
then one time we would talk about dead
people
and another one
like sex
and then one on on war and huma and so
just
and plus you like these one word title
so your latest one word title
is fuzz
and i have no idea what that means
yeah
you know what the original title i have
is animal vegetable criminal uh when and
because it's all about you know wildlife
crime prevention and people and animals
kind of getting in each other's way so i
had this great you know as animal
vegetable criminal which you know is a
great play on animal vegetable mineral
but then mark bittman came out with
animal vegetable junk and we had to like
go back to fuzz was my original title
because fuzz police fuzz fuzzy animals
get it
[Music]
i love the titles of your chapters too
they're very clever like on the road
again and
uh killing with kindness
yeah here's one uh that i bet nobody
got um well mall cops hopefully people
got and they do
get it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah uh and
there was okay there was one about
we were counting cougars out in the
boonies in california so i called it
mercurial cougars because they're you
know stealthy and hard to see but that
i'm relying on people knowing that there
was a car the mercury cougar okay how
many people oh i didn't get that part
yeah
i'm such a narcissist i thought it was a
play on my name i'm like whoa she's like
am i am i getting any royalties on this
book so so what you've done here mary
it's it from tells me that you've you
you've taken laws of civilization as we
know it
and then applied them to animals to see
which animal nature would break laws
were they doing that in our civilization
is that a fair characterization of your
book yeah yeah because animals are uh uh
i mean
they're
basically just being animals you know
they're they gotta eat they gotta crap
and they gotta find a place to live and
that but
so they're not really to them it's not
criminal behavior but they're doing it
by breaking and entering by trespassing
uh and sometimes by killing people so
you know you got murder manslaughter
home invasion with bears you got
trespassing you got littering vandal uh
jaywalking i got a chapter on jaywalking
deer and moose which kill a lot more
people than bears or lions put together
that is
mountain lions
wait wait you mean deer don't wait for
the green light to cross
do you remember do you remember there's
this woman named donna who calls or she
called some midwest radio show she goes
i've got something to talk about
i'm really annoyed i've been in two or
three uh incidents where i've hit or
nearly hit deer
and and that people are putting the deer
crossing signs in these places where
there's a lot of traffic why would they
encourage the deer to cross in this
dangerous place
and they think host is there's is like
silence he's like it sounds like you're
thinking the signs are telling the deer
where it
is
anyway everybody well everybody knows
that deers can't they deer can't read
but they can they can decipher symbols
everybody knows that so
exactly you know and they they have the
image of the deer so they recognize that
and they're like oh cross here
well in your jaywalking chapter you talk
about deer and you talk about how
swerving from deers have caused as many
or more deaths as actually hitting the
deer unless it's like we were going
through wyoming uh
my wife and another couple and we were
in a huge lincoln town car that we
rented i don't know why we hit a deer
and we didn't it was a big deal and it
hit the windshield and flipped over and
you mentioned that these
moose especially will go through the
windshield and that's when things really
get dicey for people yeah the the the
tall animals like a moose or an elk or
um
what's the other one i'm thinking camel
serious issues in saudi arabia with
camels uh because what happens you hit
you the driver you hit the animal in the
legs rather than you know if it's a
shorter animal you'd hit the torso so
the legs go out from under and they
cartwheel over and if it's a tall enough
animal like this moose with the antler
that comes through the windshield hit
you know lands on your head and so
there's like some crazy amount of
paralysis or death from hitting
a tall animal yeah wait wait wait wait
wait wait do it
camels i i can't picture camels
hiding in the bushes and then running
out unannounced this is
the terrain is not the same where you
have deer
where you don't even know the deer is
there how are you going to miss a camel
yeah i mean i've seen them in the lower
east side of manhattan they just jump
out they hide behind
yeah they hide behind a mailbox boom
there's a camel
well there was an issue that's a very
good point that you make neil degrasse
tyson very good point how do i don't
know i can tell you though that people
uh going on those roads through the
desert because there's no curves and
there's nothing they people speed like a
mother they're going fast so the camel
you know it just takes a a left turn
when you're not expecting it and
suddenly it's in the roadway i guess but
i will say there was in saudi arabia
they had a law whereby if a person hits
a camel
and kills it the driver even though the
driver is probably now paralyzed in a
wheelchair the driver has to pay the
camel owner for the camp the loss of the
camel and so some of the camel owners
would
encourage would that sort of like
encourage the camels onto the road
so as to get the money
that was a whole thing
in a journal article like the saudi
journal of medicine or i forget what
look in my backyard if you're a camel
and you're getting older you better look
over your shoulder because you're only
going to be
exact somebody pushing you out into the
street
yeah yeah i i don't want to i don't want
to get off the track too much but if you
don't mind before we get to the queries
in that same chapter you talk about how
technology
evolution of the animals
can't keep up with technology that's why
speeding cars
they can't get out of the way but they
have this innate ability which is fid is
that the if uh
yeah yeah yeah the f the flight
initiation distance which
i i was saying fid and i got corrected
but yeah so yeah animals uh evolved this
ability to look up from what they're
doing like say eating a carcass or
whatever they're doing and and to look
at they see a predator and they're like
uh oh but they're able to calculate um
at what point
do i need to flee like how close can the
predator come before i need to flee but
they wait mary mary
how many animals eating a carcass
are being chased by a predator
all right you got your your vultures you
got your birds that eat yeah but who's
chasing a vulture like nobody uh fox uh
okay i'm just thinking
you have an animal eating eating berries
and banana predators that's what i'm
thinking
all right who eats berries dudes berries
are buried bears okay carcasses see a
carcass is like that's easy meat you
didn't even have to go and you didn't oh
it's not a carcass that that you that
you were responsible for okay
you make it relatable to the city
because you mentioned that was why you
can never hit a car in a city with a
pigeon but you get a pigeon with a car
because the pigeon instinctively knows
how cl how close that car is going to
get and then takes up which is why i've
been i've been flooring it at these
pitches my whole life and i haven't been
able to kill one oh kind of i got wait i
got a fast story can i tell the story
can i tell you
okay so so paul okay so paul i've been
doing the same thing to great amazement
okay i was completely amazed the pigeons
are street savvy yeah okay
okay so now watch okay
now
all pigeons they're like gray okay
they're the same color as the pavement
the gray pigeons i was driving
north
on broadway
up near columbia in manhattan
and there was a white pigeon in the
street i never seen a white pigeon okay
with other pigeons but there's a white
one
and i said
let me see if it can get out of the way
if i speed up like every other pigeon
i've ever approached so i sped up
and
all the pigeons flew away and i didn't
see the white pigeon it wasn't anywhere
and i looked back i flattened the white
pigeon and i thought oh my gosh i killed
the pigeon and i thought
that's why there are no white pigeons
i am an evolutionary force
on the pit on the pigeons oh my god
one's got smashed
oh my god why couldn't they why don't
they have the same uh fid capability i
don't know i i survived one data point
okay then i look back it was just
completely it was a fast death for it
but i still i feel bad
so anyway mary i hand you that story oh
all right here's okay so here's what you
sped up this is the key element here you
sped up and you surpassed the species
involved ability to calculate the fin so
that's for dan
it happened to be the white one and it
was just a coincidence and that's what
happened but the i don't know because i
don't see there ain't no white pigeons
in manhattan no that white pigeon was
known as the dumb pigeon in the group
that was a little smaller
white pigeon can't jump whatever i i did
something
yeah but that's exactly right and that's
the point of that chapter is that
there's this uh was it the
they were they they did a test of 204
miles miles per hour 240 yeah
you know up till you know what however
fast a predator can run they're like i
got it he's coming now i gotta go but
they didn't evolve to they they look at
a car as a predator okay and they're
like yeah i can judge that but the car
is going 68 miles an hour and they're
like whoops splat so their processor is
like a tandy computer right now
[Laughter]
commodore 64. exactly that maybe that
would have worked that's what that white
pigeon had it had the commodore 64
processor you don't have a chance
against neil tyson on broadway
my little chickadee friend um so we are
we're at the end of this segment we uh
we'll jump to a little break here and
then we'll come back no let's do let's
slip in one let's get a question just to
wet the appetite go ahead this is from
chester lipshields dear science brains
you don't have to compliment me like
that seriously
uh dear science brains uh is it possible
that different species will be or have
been driven to a point of unnatural
alliances for their own survival in
their human surroundings could we have
created strange bedfellows that would
otherwise not have happened if not for
our dominance in the natural world
mary why wouldn't that be like rats and
mice and other things that we've co-hap
cohabitated with ever since what was the
question in there
uh there's two parts uh
uh
is it possible that different species
will be or have been driven to a point
of unnatural alliances for their own
survival
in the human surroundings
unnatural alliances in that
well there's coexistence right i mean
like so mary presumably
well presumably rats and mice predate
humans let's say or some version of
those rodents but now rats are perfectly
happy living among us their comments are
that's the that's the science brain
word they're commensal they live with us
right right and the mice they love your
barn you know and
and they love living in your basement
and so isn't that cohabitating
yeah yeah i'm not sure that's what he
was asking but for sure i mean the
animals that we that we find annoying uh
that we call nuisance animals are the
ones that were smart enough to figure
out we got the food we got the warm
place to live uh we're
going to help them survive so
i think this person is asking
essentially because the second part of
it is could we have created strange
bedfellows that we otherwise would not
have had that otherwise would not have
happened if it weren't for our dominance
in the natural world you know obviously
we've encroached on sure you know
we now uh you know we've got ski resorts
so we've gone into bear territory you
know where there's you know there's lots
of food for bears and this this is where
they hang out but now we're like
there's a restaurant with a dumpster
with all kinds of amazing like
sustainably farmed sucuna salmon and
like they're so they're like
we're gonna go down there at 3am because
it's much better than a bunch of choke
cherries and crab apples wait wait paul
paul i could imagine two bears and
they're eating the leftover salmon it
wasn't don't eat that that wasn't free
range that was fun that was fun you need
this one you're an ad one bear go see
you you're an animal you're not gonna
eat that
yes i am an animal and i am gonna eat
this i'm just happy to be in i love it
all right we're gonna wrap up this
segment yeah let's take a quick break
and when we come back more star talk
cosmic queries with friend of star talk
mary roach
we're back start talk cosmic queries and
we got mary roach
who's her publisher just let her out of
the cave one more time
for her next book uh when nature breaks
the law i got paul mercurio with me uh
paul how do we find you on social media
uh at paul mercurio uh
all across the board just real simple
and uh and my uh in my podcast the paul
mecurio show you can check me out there
too which you do yeah yeah
and who came up with that as a title for
your podcast well we uh you know we
spent a lot of time i hired a wrestler
yeah and you're marketing
i brought in donnie deutch from msnbc
and he worked the numbers and said
i know it's the time now it's i don't
like that i can't come up with a good
name all right i'll help you we'll work
on it together all right you're very
good with like play on words and mary
yeah talk to mary mary
mary's got the titles nobody understands
i got a book bonk i had so many people
go you know what i think it's boink not
bonk like i have a typo in my own title
so many people that i would do book i'd
do book talks and i would have a little
peel and stick letter i be like if you
wanted to be born here you go absolutely
the bonk was all about sex if i remember
that yeah yeah bonking bonking
right now it's blinking
so when we left off someone asked about
sort of the symbiosis that might unfold
with animals encroaching on our
turf or we encroaching on theirs and
because i told my pigeon story earlier
but i thought a lot about pigeons and i
looked them up in the book and
everything
and
they have an actual name they're called
rock doves and they that that species
lives in canyons where they swoop down
and up against the
rock walls that surround them and that's
exactly what tall buildings are in new
york city in manhattan they're the rock
canyons and so they adapted beautifully
to it
except for when they fly head-on into
the glass yeah yeah
yeah that i don't mean to laugh but yeah
that doesn't matter look pigeons don't
have eye care plants so they you know
they can't afford glasses they don't
know where they're going and you know
what bird always does that it's the
cedar wax wings we every single year
they go this book there's these berries
and somebody's property in the next
house over and they eat the berries and
this is what i'm told that they get
drunk and they're flying in a group and
uh either they're getting drunk or it's
like the blue angels where you got you
got the main person and they're all just
following the main guy so the ones on
the edge are like funk
so it's one of those two things
drunk and following the leader that's
not a way to live you know what pigeons
you know you want to be drunk and follow
no one right exactly stay home
just one
just wander into your uh
mary
pigeons i have to say i just read some
because i had blurbed this book about
pigeons by joe mancuso or something so
pigeons are actually they were
domesticated and they escaped so these
are they're basically feral animals that
that they evolved in the presence of
humans they're they're so they hang
around with us because they always hung
around with us so that's why we can
never get rid of pigeons is that right i
mean the specific variety i say that we
have
if there weren't the scraps of food in a
city like new york for example
would the pigeons be as plentiful would
there be as many pigeons if i mean
there's just no i don't know yeah they
go where the food is but they're but
they go with the foodies and they're
they're not as afraid of people you know
you know who loves pigeons is short fib
they introduced falcons into manhattan
oh yeah oh my gosh
i was when i was getting my phd at
columbia i was they put the astronomers
at the top floors of the building so the
roof was like you know six feet above my
window and there were these feathers
just dropping off the side of the
building
and i and i looked out and i went look
at that and there's this falcon just
ripping apart a pigeon and it's like
this is lunch and i thought to myself
my gosh if you're a falcon and you move
to new york
your fat lunches are just sitting there
for the taking all
in the park
you only have to work for it the falcons
are like i can't go back to new york
every time i go to that city i put on
like 20 pounds
i gotta work out for like six months i
am not going back to that city
20 pounds of pigeons exactly plus i
gotta compete with neil tyson he's
killing pigeons i'm killing pigeons no
uh should we do well give me more
questions
this is uh nicholas godlov which is an
awesome last name yeah my passion
alongside my dream of being a marine
biologist a scientist
is to educate the public on the
importance of apex predators and our
respectful relationship with them why is
it that certain humans demolish and hunt
these species
i i'll start i'll stop there there's
more to this question but let's take it
in part what do we have against apex
predators mary
uh well the um the apex predators are
the ones that are very good at uh you
know let's take a mountain lion they're
very effective killers they love to kill
deer but they'll also kill you know
small cows and sheep and other things
that you might
be keeping and using for your livelihood
so anytime you mess with somebody's
livelihood you know say if you're a
sheep herder you're a rancher or even if
you're somebody who keeps chickens in
your backyard and most of the people
requesting kill permits in california
our people we're just so a few chickens
or goats in their backyard they're not
big ranches we don't have a lot of that
so who eats the goats i guess the
mountain lions eat the goats
mountain lions eat the good goats or
chickens or pets too so that uh
people have an emotional attachment to
their own animals they're sort of an
extension
of themselves and their family and they
get very upset and they
uh
instead of taking
action like building a better nighttime
enclosure or uh trimming back the brush
so there's not a place for the mountain
lion to kind of sneak up which it needs
to do when it's hunting they just call
someone and say get rid of it or they
shoot it themselves so well that's
because it's going on there's america
yeah and we were founded on you if
you're shooting it can solve the problem
you do that first
exactly these animals are varmints
well you don't you don't box them in you
don't put a perimeter you know just
shoot it just shoot it and walk away and
have a lunch it's easy and it's like
that's it so you guys
in your book you have this chapter a
spot of trouble which it this question
sort of reminds me of that you you're
really great in the book of doing these
causal connections
and in that case in the middle himalayas
uh after the 1918 pandemic and there
were all these corpses and they couldn't
cremate so many of them they were
throwing the bodies basically down the
hill
and the republicans
yeah and the leopards got used to human
meat and made them more aggressive
towards humans which i thought was
utterly fascinating but speaking
that is the theory yep right sort of uh
the jim corbett brings that there so
it's sort of like there's this why are
we attacking these animals well we've
made them more comfortable
it's just part of us have to own the
fact that we created this problem right
yeah and the other yeah the other thing
going on there is uh so many people have
left the villages up in the middle
himalaya they used to farm they used to
terrace and farm that's a really hard
way to farm you know to get water there
and you gotta like carve out the
mountainside and a lot of people have
left for the cities so a lot of the
they call it rewilding there's uh the
brush has grown back there's not as many
people tending the livestock if you
leave your livestock out there you know
the leopards are going to come in so
yeah they've got fewer people often
children are are tending to things and
most of the
you know 41
of the kills by these leopards are kids
right so actually we presented
opportunity good hunting opportunities
for uh these leopards yeah
i see so it's i will shoot them because
otherwise they will eat me i mean that's
the rationale
yeah that is that is uh you know their
their family members are getting killed
and uh they don't wait for the
government to do something about it they
take they trap them and kill them
themselves sometimes yeah
um actually there's a there's a query
about rewilding can i jump to that oh
yeah go for it yeah this is that's a new
word for me rewilding i like yeah carrie
manaberg
uh my question is about rewilding some
people think that a parcel of disturbed
land either urban or rural can be a
beautiful natural forest if we just
simply leave it alone i take the
position that the land must be heavily
managed by conservationists and friends
in order to ensure a successful project
we must develop long-range plans
which do you think is the best approach
well do you leave it alone or do you
sort of be proactive in an urban area
i don't know i mean you know your
scenario that you talk about in the book
around these sort of plateaus on the
hill where it got so difficult to find
people abandoned right plateaus but i
guess sort of in a general sense the
question is
do you do you let it sort of reestablish
itself naturally or do you are you
proactive
in some conservation plans like i'm not
sure how you would make like introducing
animals
or
culling animals that are in there
um
i'd vote just let it do whatever nature
wants to do with it and it'll figure
something out
it'll you know yeah i'm not sure if yeah
i don't think that mine's away
sure if the concern is that it's going
to attract a kind of animal that you
don't want an urban setting whether
you're going to have too many rodents or
you're i'm not i don't know because i'm
not a
land management wildlife
management urban area
person at all but uh so
again i don't really
i would say if you look at
heavily foreign areas that required no
help from humans uh i'd say if nature
wants to grow something in your in your
in your empty lot it's gonna it's gonna
do it and and and have you driven by
sort of abandoned old diners or
something and there's grass growing
through the cracks of the parking lot
and the steps and you know give it
another couple years and you're not even
going to see
it's going to be a giant shrub right
right
it's just going to be a shrub yeah and
so and that's after just a couple of
years and you realize that when you see
something that's highly manicured
somebody's working on that sucker every
day yeah beating back the weeds and the
and trimming the grass
well you have that uh i did talk about
new zealand in in the book in new
zealand if you think of new zealand as a
really really big vacant lot
for the purposes of this question uh you
have a situation where the wildlife
didn't have natural land to predict the
birds there and it didn't have natural
land predator so they're flightless a
lot of them are flightless not all of
them so uh
now comes a bunch of rabbits were
brought in rabbits over populated people
thought hey let's bring in ferrets and
stoats to kill the rabbits while the
stones are like you know what the
rabbits are not bad but i'm really
digging these eggs
these little chickeny things these are
really good
so the populate like all these bird
species and reptile species are now gone
because the stoats and the uh ferrets
and the feral cats that were also
introduced to kind of like control the
rabbits they've all gone out out of
control so now new zealand's like hey
uh we're headed towards a point where
all we have is
rats which are from ships um feral cats
stoats and possums and that's going to
be it we're losing hundreds of our own
really cool species so you know that's a
land management conservation issue where
yeah somebody early on should have gone
let's think this through this whole
stoke thing yeah and people really never
think things through as much as they
need to right you know you raise a good
point in the book about that because
that face you you talk about sort of
it's hard you say it's hard to know
where to draw the lines what to save and
at what cost because then they started
wiping out the stones and the feral cats
and you're like well okay
who are we to decide what species to
eliminate what species to save and so
there's this it's an unanswerable
dilemma right on somewhere right right
and also you're talking about
um where do you i mean the landscape is
always evolving like the guy that was
talking about there's people who because
deer were also introduced for the
hunters to hunt and the deer are uh
they're complaining the deer are
browsing the understory in the forest so
people are like get rid of the deer but
his point was you know what we used to
have moas these giant flightless birds
that ate the understory so you're
talking about the pre-moa you know this
version of new zealand that is
you know
one period in time
uh and and i'm idealizing this one uh
this one snapshot of evolution and and
um species interactions so anyway it's
uh it's a tough call to make one thing
i've noticed from
the evolution of species on earth
is that nothing is ever constant and we
want to think of it you know from a
conservationist standpoint we think to
ourselves oh let us stabilize the
environment so that with yet if you look
through the history of things it has
never been stable ever
and
things are what we think of as balance
it might be over a short period of time
but over a long enough period of time
nothing's in balance
continental drifts you strand species
you
the the climate changes not as quickly
as we're currently changing the climate
but it has happened in the past so
yeah yeah the only thing that's constant
is change
yeah yeah
love that sentence
it's not spoken enough yes
paul we might have question time for one
more okay uh this is
taylor prim hey neil here's a question
about hacking nature have there always
uh have there been ways humans have
hacked nature so that both humans and
our neighboring wildlife individuals
benefit too
wow mary did you come across any of any
examples of that yeah there's okay
here's a here's an example that's kind
of cool um
this is i have a chapter on danger trees
which is a term that kind of cracks me
up
danger trees it's kind of like danger
mitten
it's like
it's a tree no the danger trees are in
the wizard of oz what would they throw
yeah yeah yeah
yes
actually we got to take a quick break
when we come back
we're going to learn from mary roach
about
killer trees
star talk cosmic queries
we're back start talk cosmic queries so
we left off with
mary you were describing
killer trees or no bad trees or what was
dangerous
danger trees
this is an official term this is
terminology scientific terminology okay
so how does it going so a date all right
so danger trees um
okay danger tree is a tree yeah that's
it's a
big tree that's very old it's diseased
it's leaning you can tell it's gonna
come down
relatively soon with trees relatively as
relatively soon could be 10 years 20
years but anyway so it's scary enough
that somebody has to come in and deal
with it and when it's a really big tree
one of those giant redwoods or douglas
first what they do is they don't cut it
down they they blast the top they climb
up they insert uh dynamite and they blow
off the top so now it's more stable but
it's such a big tree that it's still
sort of beautiful and people go look at
the giant beautiful tree but here's the
thing
this is the hack that i'm getting to
here because this is a question about
hacks so when you blow off the top now
you you create this situation where
water can collect there and you get top
down
decay so there's cavities formed that
animals can uh go into and live in so so
the biologists love these uh trees that
have been blown the top's been blown off
because they it it creates uh habitats
for other animals
so we blow stuff up and the biologists
like it wow in this case yes they do
they do they love it because
a dying decaying tree creates lots of um
real estate for different species and uh
the raptors like it because they're just
bare bear branches there's no uh
leaves and foliage too so does it count
i'm
on long island there are many places
where they just
people have built this perch
with a big sort of flat surface at the
top and many of them
are have bald eagles and these huge
eagle nests
and so
i'm thinking doesn't the eagle know that
like
we did that
and don't they have any dignity
they're sitting there going to each
other look at these idiots they think
we're buying into that looks like a tree
yeah
that's a perfectly formed two by four
from true value right that is not a tree
but they do have sight lines because we
tend to put them out in the middle and
they like seeing what's coming not that
eagles have predators mind you but uh
nonetheless uh so
i uh some just wanted to i guess that
that's would that that would be the
eagles
convincing us
that we should build their homes that's
what that is
yeah it's like the that's like people
bringing in uh um you know nest boxes
for owls so that the owls will kill the
rodents you know that's a you know
biological pest control kind of deal i'm
not sure if that's the hack that the
person is getting at here
as always i feel that i failed to answer
no no you're anxious
it's this chapter when when the woods
come down
and tell tell people about like i didn't
realize that there was pine cones like
this the coulter pines and the durian
trees and what they produce
and i'm afraid to walk in the woods now
because of you
explain what these things are it
freaking drops bowling balls on people
these are these are giant heavy pine
cones and they'll put there these signs
they go
falling pinecone proceed with caution
you know like who's gonna actually see
that and go oh my god don't walk under
that tree but then like people have been
and durian fruits similarly bowling ball
kind of deal big football size but dense
heavy plus spikes
it's a meal
imagine you're taking a walk nice walk
in the day and you're hitting the head
with a spiked fruit and that's how you
die
that's not how you want to buy it
they're like and there's like
photographs in the like the indonesian
newspapers you know every couple years
like a guy lying there with like a
bloody fruit next to his head it's kind
of tragic
yeah if i die i don't want to be because
of fruit assassin that i just
know
a target of a fruit
but you also say mary that we're
irrational in our uh species-specific
devotions right and talking about how to
protect these trees but these trees are
killer trees and then you know it's all
sort of relative right the same thing
with like the ocean somebody said that
they don't want to kill an octopus
because it's intelligent but they'll eat
pig and rats which are also very
intelligent like there's yeah i don't
know if they're eating the rats but
they're
all definitely we don't know what kind
of friends you have with the right
barbecue sauce
probably is pretty tasty exactly all
right give me some more yeah here we go
jeff johnson squad yeah exactly with all
the wild uh fires around the world
what's the person's name uh jeff johnson
uh with all the wildfires around the
world how much is that impacting
wildlife and what cascade effect does
this have on the environment as a whole
um
yeah mary does does wildlife just kill
the animals or the animals escape it and
then they end up living somewhere else
um apparently they're pretty i was
talking to
the guys doing the mountain lion project
here in california where he's like doing
a census of the whole state mountain
lions and he said uh um they're pretty
good at getting out of the way um and uh
they're not it's not like they're
getting burned up i know bear there's
been such bear i know there's been bears
that have been burned because they're
doing some sort of thing where they're
using tilapia skin as a
they're putting fish skin on the burns
on some bears i remember reading about
that so at least one bear didn't get out
of the way uh but um but the thing i
mean here's a you know there was this uh
i was out with this person who's doing a
census of the uh mountain lions in the
state we were up in modoc which is a
huge swath of burned wilderness and i'm
like you're looking for mountain lions
here are you crazy it's just like a
hellscape of charred sticks you know and
he's like actually look more closely all
these green shoots are coming up the
green shoots are what the deer love
because they're tender yummy you know
they eat the that's what they do in your
yard you know they eat the tender green
shoots so uh stuff springs back to life
the deer come in the mountain lions are
like hell deer yeah it's great so it
looks you know it looks like a dead
zone but uh in fact it comes back fast
and uh you have this um you know kind of
rush to take advantage of it decades it
comes back in years right yeah yeah yeah
this is this was quick this was quick so
uh that's just so so it's not nature's
first rodeo when stuff burns yeah
exactly
it's a process it's a process all right
paul give me more chaz uh
jen corelli
i just read that around uh city it's the
best way to pronounce the man's italian
name
when we're done with this we're going to
have a meatball parmesan and you're
going to like it
with a little side of spiked fruit okay
now you're getting racist but okay no
wait i'm italian i can do it oh you can
do it okay
i just read that around cities and dense
populations where high calorie human
scraps are more widely available and
predators or fewer it was discovered
that most of the mammal species studied
such as coyotes and raccoons
appear to be growing in size what
repercussions could we see from this um
well they that's
yeah absolutely uh the the more the more
food
animals get uh that even though there's
something called compensatory
reproduction whereas there's like lots
of food available the uh nature kind of
takes advantage of that by uh bigger
broods like the litters are bigger uh
and the gestation period shortens so
with some animals you just you know
they're like hey plenty of food let's
have more let's take advantage of this
and so you see this population boom and
the extreme of that is in australia with
those massive mouse plagues just i mean
you've seen there's there's uh video
from uh hundreds of years
yes yes
yes they're like dropping from the
ceiling i mean it isn't they're intense
so you so nature responds with like hey
let's go crazy so that is uh definitely
so nature's opportunistic yes yes
i read a book and forgive me for i don't
remember the name it was something like
after humans on earth so what happens
and
so
the oh yeah by uh alan
yeah the world without us it might be
there there's been several in that genre
it's amazing that's even a genre
i'm impressed that that's a genre like
people are really trying to get ready
for when we're not here and who's going
to read the book when that happens so
that's right who buys the book
so the question is how come
rats aren't bigger than they are
because
they're the right size to still escape
from you in the pipes
that we have for our sewage
if they're so big that their ass can't
fit back through the thing they die
okay so the there's no
evolutionary pressure
to have big rats because they wouldn't
be able to hide from us but if we're not
here then there's then they're not
limited by the size of their ass
relative to the pipe they want to crawl
into and they would just get bigger and
bigger and bigger and we know
that mammals
mammals
have hardly anything constraining
their size i mean the biggest animal
there ever was
is alive today and it's a it's a it's a
whale okay this the the blue whale and
the biggest animal on earth
okay
is is the african elephant but now i
guess uh you know some dinosaurs are
bigger in the past but mammals have no
trouble getting big on the in the
evolutionary tree
so maybe it is our existence that's
tamping down the size of rats i never
thought about the importance of the size
of the ass of a rat
they never collected
sorry
whatever is their widest part
actually i think they have narrow asses
i'm talking about their midsection
perhaps no whenever i see a rat i'm like
could you turn around i just want to see
wow you need to go to the gym
when i say does this make my ass
[Laughter]
does the city's infrastructure make my
ass look good
but you know the other thing you say in
the book is that sort of like pretty
animals we tend to fight harder for like
the the mountain lion the cougar right
the the
mountain right sort of like it's sort of
the
thing
it doesn't necessarily need to be fought
for but because it's a kind of cuter and
prettier
isn't it just whether they have a furry
tail doesn't it all come down to that
really yeah because you look at a roof
rat and you like right face on so you
can't see the tail
it's a squirrel and a roof rat you
cannot tell the diff they're both really
cute right and then you see the hairless
tail and then you don't like it
immediately right well what does that's
not what that's what does that say about
you neil that you would judge the rat
based on his looks and now i didn't know
i'm telling about other people who do
that he has he's got a rap that rat has
inner value man and it has an inner
sense of itself you know some people say
they don't see color i don't see species
[Laughter]
i just see big asses
and small asses on rats
uh should we do another couple more yeah
no keep coming all right okay this is
quentin we all know that humans destroy
nature to build cities and other
infrastructure but humans themselves are
part of nature do you think it's even
possible for an advanced uh civilization
of at least our human capabilities to
sustain a better balance between
wildlife and the civilization itself
oh yeah i think we can do a lot better
but starting where
um it's just starting with uh you know
look at something like
rats and raccoons i mean they're they're
a problem when you've got something
in your building or your attic or your
garage that they want a place to nest or
something to eat so get rid of that
figure out
raccoons have those creepy hands yeah
they got like yeah
yeah yeah yeah
it's like that guy that never can find
his wallet at dinner you know the hands
never go deep in like those little
yeah it's
well you know you're right about that we
had something in our it went in our
chimney and down and it sounded it was a
scratching scratching scratching and it
was like oh my god there's a rat in the
thing what did i do i went and i got i
got a baseball bat and i was ready to
you know beat it
it turned out to be a bird but still it
freaked me out and my instinct wasn't to
be civil about it at all it was right
and here's my house which encroached on
its environment
yeah yeah yeah exactly i crushed it
though with the bat what a home run i
hit no just kidding
a little birdie you killed a little
birdie oh yes so aren't quite i think
the word is speciesist where we prefer
some species over others
but like i said i don't i don't see
species so i'm i'm yeah i mean that's a
wokeness that
i'm still waiting for the world to catch
up to me you are so ahead on that
i looked at i looked at the endangered
there's like there's hundreds of
endangered or threatened
fish okay they're like
these species of sardine and sprat and
and like gill fish and lung fish but
like nobody
nobody raises money for them right
the endangered because they're not very
attractive and cute
what gets me is you know they they they
fish for tuna with nets
and they accidentally grab a
dolphin
all these people trying to say save the
dolphins only catch tuna with with a
line lying caught and i'm thinking
what about the tuna that's anybody
worried about the tuna they just they
just netted hundreds of tuna and you're
worried about the one dolphin i mean so
that's that's exactly that's that's
species dolphins are saying they're like
why what is it what did we do to them
what did we do to them yeah but the
dolphins got that you know permanent
smile on its face but there could be
like a bad evil dolphin that really
totally you know it's like it's all up
front
you know like a really not that happy
like flipper dolphin you know we're all
okay eating a turkey sandwich a chicken
sandwich a beef sandwich a pork sandwich
but if someone served dolphin sandwich
oh no can't have a dolphin
oh my god that's because it was in a tv
show if all of you
this is a tv show it's all about tv if
you get your own tv show
animal human vegetable no one's going to
mess with you you are set just before we
wrap up you know you have an interesting
thing you say in the book there's 2 000
species in 200 countries create acts
that put them at odds with man that's a
pretty big number i didn't realize that
yeah you know i kind of just pulled that
out of my ass that number yeah it seemed
that way
or did you pull it out of a big ass of a
rat
rat's ass as it was because i was stuck
in a pipe and i could get that's a sign
that we need to end this program
mary it's a delight to have you try to
put
fewer years between your books so we can
have you on more often
i'll do my best your books are all fun
and i have so many of them on my shelf
and
they are um you know not many science
writers decide to just sort of have fun
with
the intersection of humans and science
it's huge
and still learn something for having
written it and this is what you're doing
and so you as far as i'm concerned
occupy a unique niche in the science
writing landscape so thank you for
existing okay now go back to work
go back to your
cave mary always great to have you and
thanks for being such a friend of our
show
oh i love you guys come to my office and
multiple times and you've been a
wonderful guest
and we we look forward to this book and
which just came out and and who's your
publisher just some people
w norton w i that i did not know that
because they have six of my books hi
paul always good to have you back on
thanks for uh thank you a lot of fun
enjoy the book mary it's great thank you
paul thank you so much this has been
start talk cosmic queries edition all
about mary roach's latest book on the
encroachment of animals
into civilization and vice versa billy
grass tyson here for star talk as always
keep looking
[Music]